ukrainians are hiding in basements and
shelters and others are fleeing trying
to avoid the fighting and it's creating
a massive humanitarian crisis all
throughout that region this morning the
u.n said almost 900 000 people have fled
to neighboring countries that does not
even include internally displaced people
inside ukraine
crowds at some border crossings are so
large that people are now waiting up to
five days to get through christina
raffini is in poland for us talking to
refugees who tell harrowing stories
about their escape out of the war zone
in ukraine it's like hell
so
we're running
running west away from the violence
across crowded borders
here in poland the journey can take up
to 60 hours much of it by foot
amazing
goodbye this sister and brother walked
alone overnight to get to the medica
crossing their father dropped them off
as close as he could get 11 miles from
the border
but on the other side help is waiting at
a receiving center a few miles away
muhammad and his family loaded into a
van driven by volunteers all the way
from germany we decided to move as far
as we can because it wasn't safe at all
at the crowded train stations in ukraine
he says police tried to separate him
from his family saying women and
children first the priority for women
and the children okay but if there is
family should all family should be
together but after some of the worst
days of their lives they made it
together
mother-in-law natalia says thank you to
all the kind people who helped them
and
may there be peace
now ukrainian men aren't allowed to
leave muhammad has an egyptian passport
though we talked to several african
medical students at this train station
behind me yesterday all women who told
us the men in their party were prevented
from boarding trains out of ukraine even
though they're also foreign passport
holders they were told women and
children first
tony christina raffini in poland for us
christina thank you very much